hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey I'm salamander Sally
I mean Sally Lomonaco we had to bring
her
you know it's Maleficent you need a
female presence this is your favorite
movie and she loves Disney and she's
kind of borderline evil so Sally's
perfect for this Sally has borderline
personality disorder
thanks for being here Sally it's really
the three of us are in a video together
we're gonna watch this trailer for this
new Maleficent movie before we do that I
want to thank everyone who is download
and follow us on the Stardust app over
there we do 30 second reaction reviews
for any film TV show and or trailer post
micro sketches often we post daily
actually and the whole thing is
completely free to download completely
free to use so do it today let's get
into this Sally you better make this
video rewarding I will
thank you ah berries round
I remember the story of an evil witch
cover
the story became legend
[Music]
you're like full evil
okay
[Music]
the mistress of evil
I love this it still is sexy so when I
got from that now that's the subtitle
yeah I did not know that interesting
okay ice
I saw Maleficent the first one when I
first came out actually I saw Sleeping
Beauty for the first time with my
girlfriend at the Americana in the park
just last year for the first time you
see Maleficent you love Disney Jon has
not seen Maleficent but I did see wicked
I mean we were talking beforehand about
how like what the disappointment factor
was with the first Maleficent of how
essentially they took one of Disney's
most iconic villains and made her a
protagonist of sorts the cartoon is
Maleficent story Beauty Aurora is only
in it for I think 15 minutes yeah barely
in it and but yeah so we wanted to see
like I'm Alevis and origins Hanna it's
like but it was one other early
live-action adaptations and I actually
think they could do some solid
course-correction here if they really do
commit to her going full-on evil because
that's what we wanted to see it seems
like they're semi like they're obviously
picking up for where the last one left
off but they're also semi rebooting it
it feels like you know because there
were stuff here I'm like it wasn't that
in the Sleeping Beauty movie it just
seemed like it was recapping the
original tale yeah and maybe how people
perceived it seems like they went into
like let's fix this mode yeah I get that
vibe John what do you think as someone
who is being inducted is that a work
no inundated invited
generous I don't really know what I
would want from Maleficent to I am I
guess in the minority of people who
thought the idea of the first one was a
good one I like
in theory the sort of alternate take on
a well-known story and I do like the
wicked angle of what if the Evil Queen
wasn't just black and white evil but a
gray character and so now like yeah I'm
fine with the idea that like okay here's
I guess how she crested into fully
embracing her evil side I mean truly the
teasers have gotten a lot longer and I
know a lot of the us online have been
talking about that but this did feel
like a teaser it just kind of alludes to
some sort of trouble brewing between the
king and queen and there's gonna be some
kind of fallout from that and I guess my
main hope for this movie is that it
looks beautiful Angelina Jolie looks
amazing those those junk bones mantiques
and God is like popping out and like
beyond her ears at that point yeah and I
guess the main the main issue I heard
with the first one is whether or not you
like the angle they took it's just that
the performances and the effects were a
lot better than the script was and a lot
better than where they took this story
Disney live-action movie yeah for a
landscape in which a certain amount of
people are vocal about not loving the
way that they're just straight up carbon
copying they're animated movies in the
live-action something like this to me
seems like it would be more palatable
because you're at least taking something
familiar and twisting it I just hope
they put a good script under it this
time you know from from what I have been
told I mean yeah I mean from the
production design in the makeup
especially this looks a lot darker I
feel like it's gonna be dark it looks
like she is going fully it's funny after
watching Game of Thrones last night and
watch her like oh it's like the Disney
version of you know well Sal you're
gonna be in the theaters for this one
are you gonna be in Maleficent 3 if
someone pays for it then yeah I'll go um
coming from a Disney nerd like me
originally when this film came out a lot
of Disney fan
were mad because yeah she wasn't
literally her name pretty much means
evil and chaos and she wasn't really
that I like that they gave her a reason
every good villain has a reason of by
their ability and so they had that but
then she got really soft with Aurora and
was more of a motherly had like a
motherly instinct towards her which
didn't match the character at all or
even what she went through
so that was confusing so I guess I'm
hoping that with the second one she's
more evil and and just kind of doesn't
care anymore but it looks like is it
weird that I wanted her to be green and
the second one I don't know no it looks
really good but I don't know I guess I
was kind of expecting a different I
don't know what to expect with the
second one I I really don't well I think
to factoring in the what I wonder did
the first one come out Maleficent 2014
and times in terms of like social media
landscape political landscape people
being more woke than me to moving all
these things I imagine they're probably
gonna do a little bit more because there
was some criticisms the first movie guy
for certain angles it took especially
her relationship with sharlto copley and
the way they just handled certain
elements and I'm wondering I don't know
if they're gonna make like some giant
feminist angle here I don't get that
impression they're gonna be doing that
but at the same time there is that
little thing in my brain that I feel
like there's gonna be ink lling of some
subject matter that are gonna like
softly touch upon in order to enhance
the storytelling here for badass Evil
Maleficent character I feel like that's
kind of why they probably softened her
too in the first one as opposed to here
where we can go probably a little bit
more hardcore and it's a [ __ ] I think
it'd be a bold step for Disney to
actually commit to there's a mistress of
evil in the title I feel like could be a
bold step if they did commit to her
being I think that way yeah and they're
gonna reference Elvira need to have Plus
Michelle Pfeiffer's in here and she's
cool she'll show up yeah
she's one of those actresses now who
shows up she shows up and you're like
hey I like her and stuff she never gets
the shine and stuff
anymore but I like her when she's there
it also seems to me that for this
particular live-action Disney film it
seems like they're gonna go a lot more
mature with the script it seems it seems
like it's gonna be a lot heavier with
maybe the relationships of the family
and like the kingdom yeah I think that
for kids
maybe it's gonna mmm it seems like
they're the kids are gonna go to like
see some crazy like evil thing but then
the adults are gonna get the extra you
know information about like why there it
just seems like they're going way deeper
with this one and it seems like there's
gonna be less crazy effects just for the
effects we'll see it's just a teaser
trailer
yeah we'll see well guys are you excited
for Maleficent - were you demanding this
I'm sure you were before I wrap this
video up I would like to give a patron
the day shout out to a woman because
Maleficent is a woman you got to tie it
in specifically to lady named Anissa
Oliva happy belated birthday
I saw all the special posts you made
about us on your birthday
whenever you celebrate your birthday you
should make it about us that comes first
and foremost at any moment in your life
we were talking recently you were saying
that you want to get back into the Navy
continue your boot camp stuff which
automatically makes you more manly than
me
I can barely wake up to go to LA Fitness
I don't have a man landing it's
empowering
anyone can feel this power they're not
crap that just comes my way can't give a
woman a compliment anymore without being
called sexist why are you going back to
the Navy you you should be home you you
should be at home good doing the cooking
listen to Jimmy Stewart about this
subscribe notification about hopefully
the kids stayed this long
towards the end check us out on the
Stardust app and follow Sally on YouTube
where she exists